alors moi j'habite dans une Carter qui a
été construite qui apparaît 12-15 ans à
peu près c'est une petite maison ronde
qui fait 10 mètres carrés à l'intérieur
fait de paille de terre de chaux et de
chambre avec un toit végétal en partie
du moins ça fait au moins 60 ans que je
rêvais de vivre dans une maison ronde et
bien ça y est moi je suis heureux je
suis heureux dans ma cabane c'est la
simplicité je n'ai pas l'eau j'ai pas
l'électricité j'en ai un petit peu quand
même avec une avec une batterie mais
quand parfois elle est vide mais ça fait
rien je vis beaucoup avec le rythme de
la nature donc en ce moment je me couche
à 8h du soir alors que l'été je me
couche que vers 10h30 j'ai rien qui va
avec l'électricité quoi tous les engins
tous les appareils et je m'en porte très
bien parce que j'ai beaucoup plus de
temps parce que on passe beaucoup de
temps avec tous ces engins